[Música]
qué quiere usted cómo se hace
creo que esta práctica
ahí pueden ver con su bendita de gran
mano
es una difícil pregunta realmente
y luego como decís
quiere ser conocida
pero hay un énfasis
y
asumiendo que los huesos
en acción
[Música]
lo que hace es prácticamente va antes de
tus números
o sea que creo que lo que posee y existe
es más importante después pero debería
ser así
según la estadística de la universidad
nación
815 estudiantes a nivel nacional
pero de 6.215 en 50% más aire
entonces qué pasa eagles
qué está haciendo con quién está la
presión
y es que existe un gran
es decir
gracias impactos por lo tanto lola es
zapatero
martín
tanto martínez
en una etiqueta para usted
[Música]
bueno
es el futbolista de una manga que casi
nadie conoce que se llama a él
ok que utilizan hace mucho tiempo
pero
y
en el final
[Música]
la actriz en donde investigan
pero lo que no muchos saben es que ya
tienen propiedades en neurociencia
entonces este es otro
de una persona de alicante a la vez
siguiente
en mi casa
yo vengo de una familia de médicos
y existían como una cierta presión en el
aire aquí también
[Música]
de parte de mis padres quienes ya sabían
lo que yo acepté de que decir
[Música]
entonces
entonces mi familia era requerida el
doctor
[Música]
resulta que no
especificó que tiene animado de la
digital
se hacen visibles
y
[Música]
y resulta que estaba usando este año
yo estoy en constante imaginaria escrita
sentada en la cacería de su universidad
a traer tantos en azul tierra
que sepas es una muchacha muy alta y me
dice
sería sentir
como media hamburguesa
lenin o yo
[Música]
sí
cómo
no me pregunte cómo pasó eso pero
básicamente eso ya es
internacionales
[Música]
a mi mamá le decía
y
la felicidad
[Música]
cuando tenía casa
sí
tratan de visualizar
y
salía corriendo nuestro tiempo para la
clase de civilización
y tratar el sistema entonces
[Música]
y durante el día
de la mañana
[Música]
y veo el montón de personas recién
añadidas
[Música]
y
cuando lees
en el momento está animando las luces no
es una pose infalible que es el día para
que para poder dormir
sin que se terminara imaginaria y sí que
se me dé esperanza y sí que se ha jugado
[Música]
y el viernes
se puede hacer una animación
[Música]
de aquí
y
[Música]
para la sesión de fotos
como las 3 de la tarde pero tengo clases
entonces
y
pero nada
en el siglo xxi mediante
es una semilla ibarra sostiene
un concepto que las diferentes
identidades profesionales
una persona puede tener más actividad
que lo ayude a sentirse más prenda
y
[Música]
sí
bueno la corriente
y sólo éste pudiera ser una
con cuál se quedaría
sí
y
y por qué
[Música]
leamos la definición del s
es por estas razones que las personas se
sienten más
trompadas
[Música]
feliz
cuando en él
nuestra movilidad
[Música]
se piensa afectarlas
más
[Música]
diciendo
sí sí muchísimos años más algo
realmente es
la animación
entonces
[Música]
qué es
y hoy
tutorial
[Música]
eso ha hecho todo lo que ella hizo
ustedes
lo que realmente importa es lo que los
títulos
sí no
lo que haces
hoy
lo que es
[Música]
lo que dije
[Aplausos]
[Música]
están haciendo
porque cuando existe tierra
no queda lo que las obras
[Música]
nos queda no nos queda nada
lo que decimos vimos
quiero vivir con esta frase
por el tiempo que se requiere para
de todas
[Aplausos]